bull markets will make you money  but bear markets can make you rich  so if we are entering a bear market  or if we're already there okay let's use  that  to our advantage right so when  everything's going up and up and up all  right everyone's making money but if you  position yourself correctly  and you understand what's coming and and  you are prepared then you have the  opportunity to make a lot of money pat  you went off on you're a lot about to  see a lot of people worth a hundred  grand be worth a million you're allowed  to see someone who's worth a million add  another zero 10 million if you're worth  10 minutes like this is the time if you  prepare yourself  uh proper preparation prevents poor  performance right that was who i always  say yep and um  warren buffett was just quoted by elon  musk his strategy the ppp strategy which  is predict  prepare  and persevere